uh
now
like you shoot that all day long and
also you want to go do your own personal
project
um yeah because it's bigger
really that's the only effect yeah
pretty much my effect is
so i actually personally uploaded
here's the dslr and the delay
now good morning kirsten there you have
it air force one just
landed a few moments ago touching ground
here from the north side of the air park
it is now
making a u-turn to top of a j and we do
know
that it will make its way to over where
we are um the closer it will park here
and then the president will be escorted
to a hangar here
with cal fire officials there he's
expected to be meeting with
governor gavin newsom with cal fire
chief tom
porter now air force one landing right
on schedule actually was
scheduled to land just shortly before 11
different this time around
thank you
yes i can hear you
[Music]
okay
so
oh
okay
uh
yes
yes
over
um
foreign
oh
yes
great group of people hispanic people
who have done really well
and they understand exactly what's
happening and we've had
tremendous support as you know and you
can see
from uh probably everything including
polls i don't give a lot of significance
to polls even though
we've been getting very good polls we
just got a very good one from rasmussen
as you probably saw
and we certainly got a very good one
from within the republican party 95 to
96
so we're going to do our meeting now
with the state officials including the
governor
and then i'll see you in a little while
and then ultimately and we're also
giving
seven medals to seven great uh
really heroes really truly heroes and i
look forward to doing that we'll be
doing that we're gonna have a little bit
of a press conference inside
okay what would you like to see
specifically done on the issue of forest
management and is it possible
that it's also forest management and
climate change it's both things i think
something's possible i think a lot of
things are possible but
with regard to the forest when trees
fall down
after a short period of time about 18
months they've become
very dry they become really like a
matchstick
and they get up you know there's no more
water pouring through
and they become very very uh they just
explode
they can explode also leaves when you
have years of leaves dried leaves on the
ground
it just sets it up it's really a fuel
for a fire
so they have to do something about it
they also have to do cuts i mean
people don't like to do cuts but they
have to do cuts in between
so if you do have a fire and it gets
away you'll have a 50-yard cut in
between
so it won't be able to catch to the
other side they don't do that
if you go to other countries you go to
austria you go to finland you go to
many different countries and they don't
have i was talking to a head of a major
country
and he said we're a forest nation we
consider ourselves a forest nation
this was in europe i said that's a
beautiful term he said we have trees
that are far more explosive
he meant explosive in terms of fire but
we have trees that are far more
explosive than they have in california
and we don't have any problem because we
manage our forest so we have to do that
in california too
so i'll go do this and we'll see in a
little while thank you mr president you
mentioned about forest management
we've done large sections of land owned
by the federal government
and you know forest management is not
only the leaves that have been sitting
there for many years that are dry as a
bone
but they're also the trees that go over
anytime anything over 18 months that
is like a matchstick it's absolutely
like a matchstick
and the standing trees as you know
they're taking in water they're wet
and they're much harder to catch so they
have to do forest management they also
have to do cuts
50-yard cuts so that if you have a
section that goes it's not going to take
a whole
you know hundred thousand acres so you
do cuts
and you can do them in ways that look
actually very good
but you have to be able to do them so uh
you know we'll be talking about that
it's very important the management is
very important that's why you always
have them here
when you think of it you see it in
europe it doesn't happen because they
manage
well it doesn't happen much i'll have to
be exact with you people you understand
that
but it doesn't happen much because they
manage their virus and they manage to
brilliantly and they've been doing that
for many years other places it doesn't
happen where they manage
their forest and it should happen here
and they've done something
and i will tell you federal government
is now starting to do it in a very big
way but the state has to uh really do
that that includes the state of
washington that includes that
but he foreign he said force management
is a big issue governor newsom but he
said fundamentally this is a climate
crisis well that's up to him look he
does agree with me on forest management
you have to understand when i first
started talking about it three years ago
nobody agreed with me now everybody
agrees
that forest management's a very
important subject
and you can do it beautifully but if you
did manage your forest and if you
removed all of that
really dry and just it's like explosive
is the only word
you drop a cigarette on it you come back
a half hour later and you have a forest
fire
if you don't have that sitting there
nothing's going to burn
because the last thing to go the bases
of the trees because they're soaking wet
from the trees soaking up the water so
they have to be able to do that if they
do that they're going to have a much
different situation
but every year it's the same thing and
this one's a very big one this is a
number of big ones you put them together
and it's
it's a big monster
no i said it immediately and i spoke let
me just tell you
let me just tell you about your nasty
question i got a call from the governor
immediately and i called him immediately
in fact he returned my call
and on that call i declared it a
national an emergency i gave
an emergency declaration that was
immediate
so don't tell me about not doing because
i gave immediate
that included fema coming here
immediately while it was just starting
beam and everything else so that's a
nasty question
what is your relationship with governor
newsome i think it's very good we have a
good relationship
we're obviously from different sides of
the spectrum
but we have a very good relationship
we've worked well and as i said
as soon as this started we spoke right
at the beginning
and i gave a an emergency declaration
and he will tell you that he snags me
because a lot of presidents wait
for months and months and months they
wait till after it's all over
and then they consider it and then
oftentimes they don't do it i did it
right at the beginning and i think
you'll admit that
is the climate change issues in
california is there a climate change
issue in california
uh you'll have to ask the governor that
question i don't want to step up
no question thank you for making america
great again thank you very much
i like this guy i love you sorry i don't
know who you are
i need to grab it
[Music]
once okay
foreign uh
well
one
working on
oh looks like they take it off
thank you
good one
do you know where he's at
[Music]
that's like a badass
uh
okay yep
made it in
oh my goodness
i'll be back
uh okay
good
great to be with the governor we've been
speaking a lot about the uh
the problem and it's a big problem and
it'll get solved
loving respect and we say god bless you
to those that were
killed
but we are showing and give unwavering
support for the people of california
and i have to say to the state of
washington oregon
we're very much in touch with also
declaring
your declarations we have declarations
for all three
governor of california called me up and
we immediately
beside the declaration it would take a
lot longer
but we wanted it fast and i want to
thank all of the fema people for doing
such a great job
we really appreciated them and fantastic
they've been fantastic
and thank you to gavin newsom acting
secretary of homeland security fema
administrator pete gainer and
all of the people state local leaders
they join us today and
we're having a separate news conference
a little bit later on some other
subjects
and i just want to thank everybody it's
been pretty amazing in august i approved
a major
disaster declaration for california i've
approved i think gavin about 40 stafford
act declarations
so very quickly because we want to get
this thing taken care of including
fire management assistant grants to help
multiple states stop the fires
more than 28 000 firefighters and first
responders are combating the fires in
california oregon and washington over
230 soldiers are fighting
the august complex fire
and that's the largest fire in
california that's the big one that's the
biggest
and we want to thank all of the brave
fighters we want to thank these
incredible people the first responders
service members who are racing to the
extreme
peril really of their lives in extreme
danger
soon after the event i'll present the
distinguished flying cross to seven
military heroes who recently braved
raging fire and
suffocating smoke to save lives so we
have seven people that were
recommended very strongly by your
representatives and we're going to give
them a very nice metal very important
metal
for a u.s metal that's very powerful
very important so i know you like that
together we'll
keep the people safe i want to thank the
governor for the job he's done we've had
great coordination
great relationship i know we come from
different sides of the planet
but we actually have a very good
relationship good man
and uh governor would you like to say
something new
well it's great to have you back uh here
in the state mr president thank you for
being here in particular with
uh two of uh the coast guard aircrafts
that we're now bringing into
the california family that are being
retrofitted these c-130s
uh just an example another example of
the partnership between the federal
government
and the state of california that
partnership of course extended
with incredible collaborative spirit of
fema pete has done an amazing job
he's known by first name as pete out
here in the state of california
bob fenton his regional director we're
joined by tom porter the chief
of cal fire head of natural resources
wade crawford
pleased to have the fresno county mayor
here mayor mims
and of course supervisor from up north
and siskiyou
it was kind enough to come all the way
down we've got fires from siskiyou
county
uh right up there at the border of
oregon all the way down to the mexican
border
about a month ago literally to the day
we began to have a series of 14
000 lightning strikes over a three-day
period
1100 fires sparked in the last month 2.8
million acres
just in the last 30 days and burned
unprecedented in california history
3.2 million over the course of this
calendar year there's over 16 500
firefighters currently out in the lines
and i'm very pleased and i'm very
grateful mr president that you're
recognizing some of the other heroes
those national guard men
uh and women that did an extraordinary
job saving
the lives of hundreds and hundreds of
people stranded with some of these most
intense fires
you mentioned the august complex 789
000 acres the largest in california
history
we have a series of forest fires but
also brush fires
and grass fires that we're tackling
we've made great progress in the last
few weeks
uh though tragically we've lost 24 lives
so far to these battles
4 200 plus structures have been lost and
44
000 people have evacuated i want to
thank you and
acknowledge the work that you've done to
be immediate
in terms of your response to our fmag
request 14.
and we were just talking mark giladucci
is the head of the office of merged
service this may be a record
that the states received in the fmag
support uh as well as the major disaster
declaration which you referenced
on august 22nd which was profoundly
significant
not only to help us support our mutual
aid system
but also individuals that are in
desperate need of support
uh we can agree to disagree and i
appreciate your frame on
the politics of this uh but let me just
acknowledge two things briefly and i'll
turn it
back to you um there's no question when
you look past
this decade and looking past almost a
thousand plus years
that we have not done justice on our
forest management i don't think anyone
disputes that
i want to acknowledge we have uh our u.s
forest representative here
the state of california your
administration just entered into a first
type commitment over the next 20 years
to
double our vegetation management and
forest management
i want to thank you for supporting that
effort funding that effort
we acknowledge our role and
responsibility to do more in that space
but one thing is fundamental 57
of the land in this state is federal
forest
land 3 is california so we really do
need that support
uh we need that emphasis of engagement
uh and we are fully committed to working
with you to advance that cause
and final point i'd be negligent and
this is not and
we've known each other too long and uh
and as you suggest
the working relationship i i value
we obviously feel very strongly that the
hots are getting hotter
the dries are getting drier when we're
having heat domes the likes of which
we've never seen in our history
the hottest august ever the history of
the state
the ferocity these fires the drought
five plus years
losing 163 million trees to that drought
something's happened to the plumbing of
the world and
we come from a perspective humbly where
we submit
uh the science is uh in and observed
evidence
is self-evident uh that climate change
is real
and that is exacerbating this and so i
think there's an area of
at least commonality on vegetation
forest management
but please respect and i know you do
uh the difference of opinion out here as
it relates to this fundamental issue
on the issue of climate change
absolutely appreciate that
chad please well thank you mr president
for
uh coming to sacramento today and again
taking that decisive action that we
heard the governor talk about
um and and really pulling the full
resources of the federal government here
to california as well as to other areas
out here in the west
let me just reiterate the great
partnership that we have between fema
the u.s forest service
cal fire oes governor's office
it's really the partnership really a
model that we have out here in
california that
we think is just fantastic it's getting
a lot of support locally here
very quickly so i just wanted to
reiterate that and say thank you to our
partners
for what you do every day let me just
say they also do a great job on mutual
aid so they pull in a number of fire
resources from outside of the
state as well as country uh for that
matter we were talking earlier about
some international partners that they
have here and we're happy to support
that as well
and then let me just say uh thanks as
you did mr uh mr president
to the brave firefighters and all the
first responders that are responding
every day
uh to the the fires that we see here
those are the those are the heroes of
the day
uh and we're just happy to be part of
that process happy to support them with
the resources
uh through your office mr president and
and just really again look forward to
the partnership we have here and
continuing to push that along
well they're doing a great job and they
really have over the years we've uh
it's a tough it's a tough battle but
they've never let us down
incredible what they're able to do and
the risk and the danger pete gainer
please
fema
sir uh you're gonna hear this constantly
about the partnership
um i can't say enough about uh
the federal the state uh counties uh
tribes working together
out here in california from the governor
on down it is a true
team effort and i know uh you know
through the major disaster decks and the
fmags have allowed
the governor and his team to to exercise
all the resources
that the federal government has to
protect uh to respond to protect life
and that's uh the number one priority
i know what we're gonna be working on uh
debris removal
uh and then lastly uh protection of the
water uh the watershed
prevent uh follow-on uh disasters come
uh the wet season so
uh together i i couldn't ask uh uh be
prouder to be part of
this team in california that's great
thank you pete great job
let everybody uh know what we think
incredible job
so wade and tom please yeah well
from our perspective there's there is
amazing partnership on the ground and
there needs to be
uh as the governor said we've had
temperatures explode this summer
you may have learned that we broke a
world record in the death valley 130
degrees
but even in greater la 120 plus degrees
and we're seeing this warming trend make
our summers warmer but also our winter
is warmer as well
so i think one area of mutual agreement
and priority is vegetation management
but i think we want to work with you to
really recognize the changing climate
and what it means to our forests
and actually work together with that
science that science is going to be key
because if we if we ignore that science
and sort of put our head in the sand and
think it's all about vegetation
management
we're not going to succeed together
protecting californians
okay it'll start getting cooler
you just watch i wish science agreed
with you
hey well i don't think science knows
actually tom
mr president if you if you're okay i'd
like to approach the map
and yeah i'd love that oh thank you
governor good that's great thanks chief
so on my way i'll just give her
[Music]
is lands foreign service
bia plm all of the agencies including
fish and wildlife service
the yellow is all private land and then
that three percent
you can't really see it's scattered out
here that's the state lands
but what we have showing here is
the ownership and then the fires that
we're currently fighting
all the way from down up near the
mexican border within eight miles of the
mexican border all the way into oregon
so we've got a thousand miles spread
between these fires
we have about in order to put the line
around these fires with all the
partnership we're talking about
we have to cut line and scrape line in
the ground
from here to chicago so it's a lot of
dirt we have to move
but and why is that why are you doing
that you have to put a line between the
green and the black in order to put a
fire out
so what we're seeing is in the south
here
in around 2000 we had needle kill that
that that caused large fires the cedar
fire
the old fire ground free huge fires
in 2000 2010s
through the 15th time massive beetle
kill
in this area and large fires well those
trees have died anyway
from the beetle from beetles so they
were largely dead
or the area was largely dead in terms of
the trees they were not
they died from the beetle killed and
then and now they're
being burned up by the fires yeah now
we're also seeing
here's the right you view that
differently when the trees are dead and
the whole area
because i know the beetle kill has been
terrible yeah so do you view that
differently
and now you're going to be clearing it
or doing whatever you're going to do
it's 163 million so
it's uh boy it's a hell of a job right
to start clearing that out yeah
but those trees are dead and therefore
they're very flammable they're exposed
so then we have what i'll call the
asbestos forest
the redwood region doesn't burn more
than a few hundred acres
on on occasion but this year we have
85 000 plus almost 60 000
plus these fires are getting into
redwoods as well
so why is the because of the thickness
the power of the tree why
why aren't they burning they have they
have a bark that's about
two feet thick and they're very wet
they're very much they're very wet
they're very resilient to fire are you
losing
some redwoods or almost no redwoods are
dying but most of them will be okay it's
everything else that's getting
no kevin that's something i've never
heard that before
so with time they could go but but the
fact is they don't they don't go with
the fires
that's a fantastic yeah they're 2 000
years old
in that area that is so incredible
that's incredible to see think of that
yeah yeah
so that that's kind of the landscape so
your giant redwoods are where what area
the giant redwoods
we have coastal redwoods and then we
have giant sephora
which is they're the biggest girth of
the tree
and they're in good shape they're
getting burned but
they're they will also survive those
those ancient trees will survive
but this fire down here the sqf complex
will the bark regenerate on the outside
eventually
the park will continue to accumulate on
the outside and then
the tree will continue do you see a big
difference yes
you see will that change with time where
you don't see it
or will you always know there was a fire
there you'll always know
on the red ones yeah they get scars yeah
over time that's how we can tell well
that in itself is a shame when you think
right
that in itself is a shame so that's an
incredible story thank you very much
appreciate it
mark would you like to say something
welcome mr president
first of all thanks for being here um
the term i use here is is a term i use
one team one fight and it really does
represent everything that that you're
seeing today all the agencies that
we're working with before during and
then
after these disasters occur i couldn't
be more pleased our partnership with
fema has been
fantastic um right now you know as you
mentioned you've provided a major
disaster for
uh 11 counties within the state
different categories and
many of the people who have lost things
have already started to register with
fema and that's been
really a beneficial support to us right
so we appreciate that
and the mitigation is really really
critical um uh
you know since 2017 we've done 94
projects about 138 million dollars
worth of mitigation focused on fire
prevention
uh it's a whole variety of different
kinds of projects and programs within
the wildland and people what we call the
wui the wildland urban interface
uh to try to buy down the the amount of
impacts that these fires are occurring
and so we really appreciate that all
these new fires and this new declaration
uh provides additional mitigation funds
which we will turn back around and
and continue to uh support them how many
individual fires do you have
i think we have right now actively about
29
major buyers so when you add them all up
uh
this is about as big as it's ever been
right
yeah i mean well eleven hundred just
just since i mean
think about that eleven hundred fire
starts in the last 29 days
with 29 complexes so we all put them out
most of them are put out
making tremendous progress the largest
the three largest
they're still active two of them are
substantially contained
the august we have still a lot of work
to do and governor if i could just for
the president uh this is a bar
chart that shows the uh acreage burned
over the years
top bar is this year and the real scary
part mr president is we're only part way
through the season
right right the worst fire that you
obviously visited the paradise fire
happened in october
so we're still you know staring down the
barrel of of worst fires potentially
this year
they're together let me ask you in
paradise so did they have
it was like a blowtorch right because
the winds are 85 miles an hour nobody's
ever seen anything like that so that was
different
has there ever been anything like that
in terms of the power it could be argued
you had a narrow escape
a more playable female might better see
there will be
no other female
so justice
that's a lot of uh it's a lot of
utilities that are burning up though
yeah go ahead so our
our fire right now is over 200 000 acres
um and it's really more than any single
local government can take care of and so
we are asking for assistance and we've
already made
some progress today by getting a hold of
fema and i made a request
from pete to have a representative right
in our command post and
we're making that happen so that's going
to be very valuable for us
not only has it impacted our woodland
but the families that have lived there
for generations
in that area the big creek hydroelectric
power generating system that served
california for over a hundred years is
is destroyed as well as the people that
live there in
their homes that operate that system one
major concern in the future
is erosion slope stability ash runoff
and possible meds lines as well so
what's going to take the place of that
generator what
what are you going to do we have to
actually
restart it it's southern california
edison so you'll be able to fix it and
restart it yeah
yes
it's a big damage well it was a
hydroelectric plant that was um that was
uh
uh wasn't directly damaged but there was
there was
damage leading up to the facility and so
we'll mitigate all that now i love hydro
hydro electric i love i think it's great
you must like that
i love the hydroelectric go ahead please
so so far we've had over 300 structures
that have burned but we could have had
many more and i need to commend
the uh efforts that cal fire gave to us
not only with pre-work
by doing some tree mortality mitigation
right but during that fire they were
able to cut some breaks that
allowed us law enforcement to evacuate
over 20
000 people from these areas and so they
just
did a great job and and i'm i am glad to
report that in fresno county we've had
no loss of life right um and i will say
that
in fresno county we we understand we
need a strong partnership
with our federal government and we are
ready willing and able to be your
partner
on this we support uh and your state
government
and of course of course that's going
good right of course
we're getting no doubt in fact
of the areas that were mitigated i think
in cap fresno county we got five of
those so you're working well with
everybody yes
okay yes good thank you very much i
appreciate it thank you
please thank you mr president for
on thank you mr president for being here
and listening to
a very rural community and county in
in california i'm at the far extreme end
of the state
up there they were pointing to my county
uh continues to repeat the things that
you saw
in paradise when you were there on a
smaller scale
the town of happy camp this year is
under the slater fire
that took off and in a 24-hour period
we lost uh 258 structures in a very
small town
half of my population is displaced at
this point in time
we have 158 homes completely destroyed
will that population come back
sir that's a tough question because
these are very poor people anyway
and they're living through the downturn
of the timber economy
at this point and there's very low
employment
uh in this area we uh
are completely surrounded by federal
timber
at this point that uh needs some active
forest management that would both
improve the
economy of the area as well as uh even
increase the water flow
uh that is in shortage in california in
some of these places
i you know personally i'm coming to you
as a forester
uh elected official and a past land
manager for the u.s forest service and
firefighter
right um in this area i've worked with
uc berkeley and uc davi
and uc merced on some studies our
forests
uh in the northern region which
historically
have been pretty asbestos-like
are carrying four times the density that
they did in 1930
so we have both the increase in brush in
the wildland interface
as well as the lack of management
producing these extreme densities
and um climate climate change is
climate changes and i can't do much
about that
as a as a forester actively managing
that forest i can manipulate
fuels and i can do that in a pretty
short order i applaud you for the work
you've done i applaud you for the
farm bill authorities our county just
completed
a master stewardship agreement with the
u.s forest service
and we have about a half million acre
project that's ready to go
uh across all boundaries in our state
and
and the four national forests that you
would think well gavin's working on that
with me
and uh we you know you make money too
you
you're cutting down trees you're
thinning it out and you're selling those
trees for a lot of money and
it's really pretty good in a lot of ways
and i guess the
one of the things are the cuts the big
whether it's 50 yards or 100 yards but
the cuts
to stop it from spreading and that's
always tough environmentally but
you know they can do it in a way that's
pretty good and i think now the
environmentalists have come a long way
after watch you know watching this
yeah the ones that really want to take
care of a problem they've come a long
way
so they'll be thinning it out then
you're working on a plan to thin it out
that's what the plan is right now i i
will say that um
you know we have uh excellent working
relationships with cal fire as well
good and uh we need we need to marry the
state
programs with the federal programs uh
across boundaries and jurisdictional
boundaries
so that we're effective in moderating
large fire behavior good
and mr president just to the
supervisor's point that's exactly what
the stewardship partnership
that we advance with your
administrations do will do in the next
20 years is we're sharing maps we're
sharing resources
we're prioritizing we're doubling the
number of acres
federally managed state managed and i
will say just
uh humbly we've got to double it still
meaning
the partnership was significant it's
first uh in california's history with
the us
government but we're going to need to do
a lot more
that's something i feel so strongly
about you can you can knock this down to
nothing you know you go to europe and
different places in europe countries
where they're forest countries and
they're very very strong on management
and they don't have a problem they
really don't have with
as they say more explosive trees that we
have in california so
thank you very much for your comments
but we're working on that very hard
together and
uh i think we're totally in sync i
really think we're totally in sync
governor we're going to see you in uh a
few minutes for
the award ceremony so thank you very
much
everybody thank you yeah go ahead please
governor if i could just just
just briefly
you